[Musique]
on continue de parler sport dans cette
émission avec michael et nico bonsoir en
ingénierie comme chaque lundi vous venez
nous présenter les principaux résultats
du week end dans le département
et on commence michael par un sport qui
vous plaît je le sais c'est le volley
ball
je peux rien vous cacher un grégory je
vais vous emmener du côté de
vélizy-villacoublay tous les signaux
sont au vert pour l'équipe féminine
senior en nationale 3 ce week-end les
bélizienne se sont imposés dans leur
gymnase trois sets à zéro elles ont
remporté leur cinquième victoire de la
saison en six matches disputés le score
25 à 20 25 11 et 25 à 8
écoutez les réactions balade de santé
dans le premier set n'était pas la
réalité plutôt série justement c'est en
psycho logiquement se mettre dedans et
on la prépare la suite effectivement ça
s'est érodée on a été plus propre dans
le fond de jeu
ça aide cole satisfait par rapport à la
causerie d'avant match
justement on a essayé d'appuyer sur le
fait de jouer ensemble se faire plaisir
et de tenir le jeu qu'on a pas tenu sur
les derniers matches dans la régularité
donc bonne réaction des filles avec
cette victoire à levi lysienne conserve
la première place du championnat de
nationale 3 devant argenteuil
mais le promu le sens flaba écoutez donc
l'installer c'est une année de plaisir
où maintenant les filles commencent à
chercher justement à faire des résultats
mais les objectifs du club
c'est de se maintenir noah s'est dit ses
dauphins le tableau est plus avare et
puis ici sont gourmandes donc on va
avancer
pour continuer à rêver d'une montée en
nationale 2 vélizy devra s'imposer le 17
novembre prochain face à son dauphin au
classement argenteuil après un sport de
balle un sport collectif et qu'elle y
avait également du football seront
jouées en première division de district
6e journée à ce week-end plaisir s'est
imposé dans la douleur 2-1 contre marly
le roi lui au cours de mines
sartrouville 3-2 maurepas s'incline 3 à
0 contre où il y à l'extérieur c'était
journée portes ouvertes en revanche dans
la défense de montesson les genres en
pris l'eau sur le terrain de carrière
grésillons 10 à 1
héloïse comme on appelle valises c'est
exactement le chesnais s'offrent le fc
mantois le fc mantois 4 à 3 dans un
festival offensif enfin à gargenville
s'impose contre hardricourt 3 le
championnat est dominé à part d'hui en
cours merci michael et on retrouvera
tous ces résultats dans votre émission
de statut de port c'est ça avec les
instants à suivre sur cave et 78